mal im spiegel sah diese frisur gerade
hammer aus ja wir leben jetzt einfach
mit einer frisur nicht 100 prozent
perfekt oder vielleicht doch und meine
ansprüche sind nur zu hoch hallo leute
hier sind eure wahl waren und willkommen
zu diesem ganz speziellen
adventskalender auspackt video heute
mache ich etwas was ich noch nie gemacht
habe witzig sein
nein ich habe ein adventskalender
bestellt den jemand privat verpackt hat
also nicht ganz privat ich glaube das
ist schon so ein business ein bisschen
auf rc aber es ist von einer
privatperson und keiner firma ja es ist
ein also ich habe mir einfach gedacht es
gibt es selbstgemachte sachen warum
sollte es da nicht auch ein
adventskalender geben dann habe ich das
da eingegeben und dann kam wirklich zwei
adventskalender das ist nun mal ein und
es gibt noch einen anderen der ist noch
nicht angekommen ja und die packen heute
auch selbst gemacht das ist quasi denn
hier kein partner freund kinder habt ihr
euch ein bastel dann habt ihr immer noch
das gefühl healthcare medical zeit dann
habt ihr immer noch das gefühl dass sich
jemand um euch sorgt
denn hier
hier gibt es eine box das brauche ich
alles nicht wegschmeißen ich verlosen
wenn es kalender auf meinem instagram
account da kann die adventskalender fall
gewinnen die ich selber verpackt hat die
adventskalender kostet 72 euro plus 11
euro versand denn er kommt aus den
niederlanden also das habe ich gar nicht
gesehen ich wusste nur dass es viel
versand ist und ich habe ihn geholt weil
dort dürft kerzenwachs mädel steine drin
sein sollen und da bin ich ja ein großer
fan von ich kenne aber diesen habilis
creations account nicht also ich weiß
jetzt nicht genau was die machen ich
wollte mich einfach mal überraschen
lassen von seinem selbst gebastelt und
ja wir packen den jetzt einfach mal
gemeinsam aus 72 euro das ist spannend
dieser duft der von dem adventskalender
ausgeht ist sehr intensiv und nochmals
luft folie ich finde den gedanken so
cool dass da jemand sich ein shop
aufgemacht hat und einfach so selbst
gebastelte adventskalender verschicken
ich kein youtube mehr mache dann möchte
ich genau so was machen dann sollte das
echte geld verdienen und ich verdiene
erzielt
wenn lasch und douglas ein baby machen
würden dann hätten wir diesen geruch der
hier gerade aufsteigen war auch
es ist ein intensiver duft ich weiß
nicht was da drin ist was so intensiv
riecht wahrscheinlich mehrere sachen
gemischt so im ja jetzt bewerten wir
hier erst meine also corp es ist ein
schöner standard korbach hat dann noch
so ein geschenk schleife rein gemacht
und darin befinden sich einfach selbst
verpackte dinge also so zum beispiel
sieht es dann aus was gibt es denn
bessere so kann man das toll verschenken
also wenn ihr jemand ein adventskalender
macht und nicht irgendwie eine krasse
konstruktion an der wand bauen wollen
oder so machen körbchen packte die
türchen rein und gut ist sehr sehr
hübsch
jetzt müssen wir nur die türchen finden
eine karte erkannte hettinger
rennkalender zu färben anyone to think
you for your support and hope you enjoy
the counter
antichrist loss of life milliliter und
anthony vielleicht erreicht ja dieses
video okay mein erster eindruck ist
absolut positiv ist
so ein süßes lindern aber der duft der
duft ist mir nur was zu deutsch wir an
mit türchen nummer eins dieser sommer
richtige geschenke auch macht die glocke
behalten natürlich für unsere eigenen
geschenke
doppel sakko und hier haben wir schon
mal das duftsäckchen also definitiv
lavendel und
ganz viele andere ja ja so lavendel und
so was nicht sehr angenehm das ist ein
bisschen problematisch bei diesen
körbchen findet man halt die päckchen
nicht so schnell man muss ja jetzt ganz
schlimm darum suchen und die nummer 22
kleine geschenke nummer zwei
ins helfen
wir haben unseren ersten kristall das
ist ein pool wright pyrit für insight
health knowledge memories und happiness
wenn ich diesen stein ist und die hand
nehmen
erinnere ich mich an
meinen happy memories
der kommt jetzt eine stein sammlung
selbstbewusstsein für erinnerung und
happiness koffer und ihr könnt ihr könnt
doch nicht so ein stein wird und nicht
daran glauben dass der zauberkräfte hat
wirklich
und wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
das ist mit so viel liebe patent nummer
3 haben wir organische clover kamille
und
marie gold was macht man damit ist das
gt
ich kann das nicht einfach
ist
wir können's trinken ja gut dastand ganz
ganz klein gesteht ganz kleine obendrauf
herald deswegen habe ich das nicht
gelesen türchen nummer 4 schenk nummer 4
72 euro dafür bezahlt ist kein schimmel
oder kommt auch intensiver duft daraus
okay kommt jetzt einfach hier so lohse
nachhaltig natürlich gern hubble mit
time vor ort im feuer nadel
orangerie
ja was sind märz das ist die große frage
ich habe keine ahnung ich suche einfach
mal das wort wachs mails ja aber was
sind bugs mails aha ich habe
herausgefunden man packt dieses wachs
made in so eine schüssel und unten ist
ein teelicht und dann schmilzt ist und
es riecht wahrscheinlich gut das ist so
der gedanke dahinter das riecht all das
ist richtig richtig gut geschmeckt
schaut euch mal wie das verpacken es
hier ist und säckchen dran und dann mit
klammer dann kann man das für sein
eigenes geschenk an co2
sind wir deswegen haben sie nach meinem
geburtstag gefragt eine kerze weil ich
bin also jungfrau vom sternzeichen
centered kenneth clarke walkman mit
quartz ist da ist ein quarz drin ich
weine vor freude sie haben ein edelstein
der eingeschmolzen glaube mandarine
violet und sadovic zedernholz glaube ich
sehr gut also ja ich find das zedernholz
ist glaube ich an intensivsten das ist
so schwer euch gerüche zu beschreiben
riecht gut und unten work ot leute mit
jerome kilian pfeffer und majoran darin
lassen sich aber nicht bestechen von
irgendwelchen bürger kerzen türchen
nummer sechs nikolaus und ich weiß aber
nicht ob man in den niederlanden
wirklich nikolausfeier ihr könnt mir das
nicht erzählen dass ihr das nicht auch
so passt es ist doch so süß aus
handelfmeter 6 in tücher nummer sechs
ist wieder ein edelstein drin wie
präsentiere ich den am besten so so der
hat hier auch so was dran
das ist der blaue agathe der es für
wachstum evolution passion motivation
und die feminine mg
news burger bei kauf des korsen
tour-pause crystals auf das entbehrt
also hier kleiner tipp von denen einfach
dort aufbewahren sehr schön das ist ein
wort über weckte kalender für mich ist
ich kann es nicht mal ich kann es nicht
neutral bewerten die ich an nummer 7
[Applaus]
einem und stone kerze fänden energy und
sehr gut sie riecht nach rosmarin und
ist aus soja wachs ich glaube alle
karten sind auch so erwachsen muss man
ihn nicht meine nase zeit auf und dann
zum 5 und dann kommt da der stein raus
natürlich normal ist auch ein
christdemokrat für abenteuer
flexibilität werbung das heißt es in der
ps und balance für inneren frieden und
balance ist der hier
innere friede
das eine mischung aus jaspis opa lied
und hornstein gefunden bitte
ausschließlich in australien und erhielt
dort seinen namen von den aborigines
aborigines fanden ihn an einem fluss und
benannten ihm nach muca deutsch
fließendes wasser jetzt kommt mein
lieblings türchen türchen nummer 9 sie
wussten es und haben so ein großes paket
reingepackt wir haben es einfach gespürt
durch die macht der zauberstein
bücherei packet
okay das ist hier noch mit seiner
verpackung drin und man kann dann so ein
suncatcher machen ich glaube ich schaffe
es jetzt aber mit meinen fingernägeln
nicht nee das ist doch natürlichen nun
als es ist ein spice nix mit orange zimt
apfel juni per berlin anis und klar
fest
juli per berisha und clogs ist jetzt
bestimmt los heißt nicken so und jetzt
passt auch spies mix in nissans kennen
also in einem eck schoss mx ist so
merkel weiter also wasser daraufhin
tietze pen oberloher android also man
möchte das so ein bisschen und dann geht
es nur um den geruch der das abgibt wird
kosten da an der fahne nix ich mache
hier nochmal gerade meine fragrance
mischung stimmt es auch superschlauen
nachteil sind aber ja also
ja hier kein ok ok türchen nummer elf
assen der hektischen angekommen ich
glaube hier ist eine kerze drin aber ich
bin mir nicht so sicher
mache dieses jahr sowieso adventskranz
wo ich dann so edelsteine drumherum wege
und so glitzer und so ein bisschen ja
esoterisch aus blue colour doni
communication und connection also da
drin ist der blaue kolonie und der duft
der kerze sich aus wien
haben ich beschreibe ich euch dass das
riecht einfach sauber rein die mit
erfolg schließen sie an dürfte es im
badezimmer ja und da verbirgt sich halt
dann wieder so ein tierchen damals war
ich muss unbedingt wieder zur maniküre
meine fingernägel sind viel zu lang
geworden wie der
glaube sind die air
france rose rosmarin und cacau nicht die
hände des adventskalenders rum und jetzt
machen wir weil damit das recht
natürlich wieder was hartes
lavendel quartz haben die test und
rosenquarz ihr was ist es denn jetzt ist
ein artist oder notarzt hierfür nur ein
stein innerer frieden intuition
spirituelles wachsen und liebe aber ich
bin ein bisschen verwirrt hier steht
neben der emnid ist und große quads aber
ein amt ist und grossisten quasi zwei
verschiedene dinge und darüber steht
nach lavendel lavender quasi also ein
hybrid von zwei steinen habe ein paar
macken wurde der zusammengeklebt ich
weiß es aber ich respektiere natürlich
jeden edelstein hier nochmal 14 was war
wirklich in natürlich immer 14 es ist
wieder in der kerzenform denke
die wieder toll aus sie schön und das
darin einfach also es ist einfach mit
toller kerl und jetzt verstehe ich auch
warum es so ruhig wie es riecht denn es
sind einfach drei millionen verschiedene
dürfte hier teilt josef blum orange
lavendel zitronengras diagramm und
bergamont berger montrose beim rosa
vanille
[Musik]
ja muss ja nicht alles so krass
weihnachtlich seien es jetzt nicht so
weihnachtlich aber dieses dieser look
von diesem ganzen blüten da oben drauf
gewartet ihr hier noch mal sanft senders
schnappe ich mir gleich für meine
eigenen geschenke eine
art print glossy verstehen ich noch
nicht
also ja ein 1 1 art print eine postkarte
und und ein stück pizza papier ja das
habe ich mit 72 euro gemacht nummer 15
wieder von duft erschlagen habe ich
wieder diese märz die man schmelzen muss
simone grapefruit galip tus und
pfefferminz
sämtliche videos für den 70
es ist dass das sieht aber selbst
gebastelt dort ist das selbstgebastelte
firma magic stars pockets eis und kommt
sehr smart bei der mission dort oft wenn
ich das jetzt hier gerade richtig lese
dann ist das ein super mega power stein
der infiniti stone ist nichts dagegen
wenig grad nicht selber enttäuschende
aber so kommt guckt euch das mal an hier
sonst sagt so wie der ausgang an das ist
kennt ihr diese videos auftakt obwohl
sie so dieses flüssige plastik irgendwo
rein kippen und dann sieht es ganz cool
aus gescher heißt es oder nicht na ja
auf jeden fall ist das ein
selbstgemachter stein mit so einer
plastik mische und glitzer und so aber
sie haben eine gute intention dabei
gehabt steht da und deswegen bringt
dieser steine und ganz vielen aber da
hört meine matt also da hat mein glaube
an übernatürlichem auf aber er sieht
wunderschön aus also ich stelle mir hier
hin und erfreue mich natürlich nummer 18
mit super dicke okay okay okay es ist
etwa wieder eine
kerze fresh snow and sweet kenn di centa
es riecht nach süßigkeiten und sie haben
da so kleine glitzersterne drauf gemacht
wäre ich wie erster schnee und
zuckerwatte 19
was ist das wieder so ein
schmelztiegel war wie so ein stück seife
lavendel patchouli zimt yang yang und
pinien atmail
sehr schön riecht wirklich richtig ich
mag einfach in die anwender die hierüber
instagram verlosen werde einfach mal so
ein mail mit rein das riecht dann mega
gut verwirrt euch so sind in den 20ern
angekommen was könnte ich hier drin sein
tisch nummer 20
eine kerze na klar take your time
lavendel fragen pings ins gremium keine
ahnung auf street aber ganz so starken
21 hier ist irgendwas ausgelaufen das
sieht sehr üblich aus so irgendwas
irgendwas ist da drin basiert ja ja
wirklich an ihrer idee das ist hier so
ein duft ding mit denen genau also hier
haben wir die stäbchen ja das ist hier
so ein bisschen hat sich gehört auch
sieht das herrlich aus raum die user
orange zimt anis und
klopft das riecht sehr sehr gut sehr
hochwertig
wir wollen und schon haben wir unseren
raum diffuse machen wir weiter mit
gewaschenen händen und türchen nummer 22
euro pro tier oprahs
reinigend positive adp kompetenz
kreativität akzeptanz und spiritualität
klein aber oho gemacht mir gleich in
meinen buben die power die möchte ich
haben
vor letztes türchen nummer 23
nun eröffnen wir noch mal einen tee weil
wir uns natürlich noch mal ein thema
time for winter linie juniper das war
jetzt ein teenager war heute irgendwie
und ist sehr schlecht aufgedruckt
irgendein blut
es ist zeit für den 24 wir haben uns
durch den ganzen advent gedriftet haben
kerzen angemacht und sachen geschmolzen
wir haben edelsteine angehimmelt und nun
ist der 24 es ist heiligabend und wir
eröffnen diese kalender und bekommen the
working ohne conversion negativ energie
in positive energie enhance the power of
the crystals in contens also hier so
eine schachtel
dafür sind zwar ein bisschen drin
also wie ihr seht das ist so selbst
gegossen da gibt's tolle form denke ich
mal und dann kommt man dann so sachen
ein also ich sie dabei sehr schön aus
also das was macht dieser die frage ist
eher was macht dieser stein nicht oder
dieses selbst gegossene ding macht
negativen energie weg macht eine gute
atmosphäre
machten gute nacht schlafe
bringt harmonie und erhöht die vibration
der frequency die zu hause herrscht
seine spiritualität wird gefördert und
man muss sie nicht aufladen
aber wie gesagt ne also diese hülle von
dem ding ist genauso echt wie meine
acryl wohnen energie so öko energie nach
wilhelm reich eine universelle kosmische
energie vor vergleichbar mit jeder
energie sigmund freud metaphorisch
libido nannte hierfür reicht jedoch wie
elektrizität und magnetismus eine an
ihren wirkungen erkennbaren und
beschreibt und beschreibbare kraft war
da will ich jetzt echt hart verriet wald
davon habe ich noch nie was gehört
dieses ding hier also das ist wirklich
sehr schön das ist ein toller keine
ahnung papiere liegen auf dem tisch was
kann man da drauf legen sonst ja aber es
ist viel spaß es ist nicht sache da ich
sag nicht sofort haben wir das jetzt
frag mal zusammen märz die steinchen
diesen steinchen drin ein steinchen habe
ich im publikum
und hier kehrt gemacht dieses jahr auf
jeden fall ein esoteriker adventskranz
schön mit diesen esoterik herzen noch
diese zwei kerzen wie konnte ich hier
mein baby vergessen
und hier mein organ eine öko energien
also ich habe
83 euro ausgegeben für rolle handarbeit
an erster stelle erst mal die positiven
sachen gute materialien werden verwendet
der tee ist bestimmt auch ganz super die
kerzen da riecht alles fantastisch da
sind ja auch noch überlege steine drin
ich habe sogar noch einen stein meine
puppe also dieser länder ist erstens
glaube ich für leute die wirklich sehr
dort dran glauben wohl waren glaubten an
tee oder was sie sagt wenn es kalender
ist für leute die sehr viel geld haben
weil 70 durch 54 sie haben pro türchen
drei euro kostet denn so eine scheiße
auf deren shop diese märz wie viele märz
kriegt man damit eine märz 66 mit
würfeln wir sind drei her gut diese
mails kosten das schon mal vier euro pro
säckchen das sind dann schon mal nicht
drei dass das ein edelstein
der in masse einkauf kostet der halt
nicht drei euro pro stück ja es ist
schwer das zu berechneten ob es sich
lohnt oder nicht keine ahnung dass es
ein handgemachtes zwei jahre von der
menge her ist das ein bisschen habe ich
drei euro jetzt hier so eine packung
theorie mussten natürlich auch was dran
verdienen das ist ja jetzt keiner band
kalender mit denen man kunden einfach
irgendwie schon zufrieden stellt wie
jetzt zum beispiel mittels oder so wo es
ja auch ein bisschen marketing ist ein
guter ein adventskalender zu haben
deswegen und sieht also das ist ein
geschäftsmodell adventskalender basteln
und geld damit zu verdienen deswegen
darf nicht jedes türchen drei euro
kosten deswegen müssen sie mit jedem
türchen auch was verdienen sie haben ja
auch alles hand verpackt das geht nicht
mal eben so das dauert auch es stimmt
wenn sie es dann auch selber machen ja
aber
braucht man es nein natürlich nicht man
braucht so ein adventskalender nicht
wenn man das geld übrig hat und da so
ein fan von ist dann kann man das
bestimmt dafür ausgeben aber 1 70 euro
sind 72 euro wenn ihr jemanden kennt der
auch gerne edelsteine mag und kerzen und
tieren ist das ein super konzept für ein
adventskalender weihnachten selbst dann
setzt euch danach mit der kinder
gestellt ein paar steine oder holt euch
den aus dem kristall laden um die ecke
dann macht ihr euch eine schöne
adventskalender also 72 eurocent je mehr
du bist ja das ist extrem viel für diese
sache aber eh ich meine jetzt habe ich
ein organ okon naja ich habe jetzt auf
jeden fall so ein herz natürlich hallo
sich viele sachen also folgt mir
wintertraum die verlosungen der
adventskalender nicht zu verpassen und
wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten
auspackt video hier heißt die macher von
diesem adventskalender das hier sehen
ist ein super kalender jetzt toll
gemacht jetzt gesehen ist jetzt
vielleicht nicht alles meint gewesen
aber danke schön